in my opinion the most interesting model
and again i don't want to go too long
with this segment is the uh the dual
intervention point model and it also
um
acknowledges the fact that there are
compensated and uncompensated or
physiological and non-physiological
factors that dictate body weight
regulation but it basically makes the
argument that we've got an upper
intervention point and a lower
intervention point and we can think of
this as kind of the upper and lower body
weight range that we feel really
comfortable in
and our behaviors our eating environment
psychological aspects related to food
that will kind of dictate when we're
fluctuating toward the higher end of
that range or the lower end but then
once we get beyond a certain point some
of those physiological feedback loops
kick in and they really do constrain our
weight change beyond a certain level so
like for me personally i can easily bulk
up to about 185 if i try to bulk up two
higher than like to too much above like
195
my appetite just like shuts down um i
can cut down to
160 pretty easily once i start getting
155 150 my hunger's through the roof my
energy expenditure tanks
so this kind of resonates with me
because i know
my body weight can kind of drift around
between
you know 160 and 180 something like that
i i forget what numbers i i threw out
earlier but that's kind of the general
range where
you know just kind of
environmental changes behavioral changes
my weight will float around in there but
it's pretty clear when you start to bump
into your upper and lower intervention
points and you're starting to get
pretty significant feedback from your
body that's like yeah dude you're
heavier than you like to be your
appetite is just cut or you know you
start getting super low and it's like
hey you you really ought to eat more
like hungers through the roof energy
expenditures down so i personally think
that the dual intervention point model
is a very um
a very solid way to conceptualize body
weight regulation and i would highly
encourage people to check that out for
more information but if you ever see me
in a facebook group saying yeah i'm not
really into body fat set points as a
comprehensive theory
it's because i think this dual
intervention theory makes a lot more
sense